[Musique]
archives de la campagne présidentielle
de 74 ou le tout premier candidat
écologiste casse le ronron politique
pour nous alerter sur des dangers futurs
[Musique]
vous savez ce qui va se passer et bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis
Nathalie Arthaud est-ce que la nature
l'environnement le bien-être animal
est-ce que ça fait partie de vos combats
ou est-ce que ça vous paraît secondaire
bien sûr que ça fait partie de mes
combats alors là c'est une archive de 74
vous avez voilà qui était candidats
de la nuit
souvent nous on nous accuse de
de dire et de répéter le même discours
depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans depuis 50
ans mais je vois que lui c'est pareil
les écologistes ils sont face à la même
à la même situation en fait enfin vous
voyez voilà il y a parce que parce que
ce système capitaliste la réalité c'est
qu'il exploite les hommes autant qu'il
exploite la nature et il les exploitent
jusqu'à leur extrême limite jusqu'à les
détruire moi c'est ce qui me frappe dans
cette dans ce système là tout est bon
pour faire du fric tout alors bon on a
vu le scandale des EHPAD vous avez vu
même même les derniers jours de de notre
vie servent à faire à faire du fric pour
certains mais la nature c'est pareil
donc pour moi c'est le même combat tout
ça on peut pas accepter que il y ait une
minorité qui capitaliste qui ne jure que
par leur fric et après moi le déluge
mais c'est ça qui se passe c'est ces
grandes multinationales totales mais
dans la groalimentaire c'est la même
chose et moi ce que je ce que ce que
j'ai quand même envie de dire
aujourd'hui c'est que on leur fait
confiance à eux à ceux qui ont pollué à
ceux qui ont détruit la planète on leur
fait confiance pour que pour faire la
transition énergétique pour que demain
en fait on respecte les ressources
naturelles on leur fait confiance mais
mais comment leur faire confiance ce
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas possible
alors moi oui je prétends d'ailleurs
dans cette campagne avoir le programme
le plus conséquent en matière écologique
pourquoi parce que je suis pour
l'expropriation de ces grandes
multinationales et pour qu'on les prenne
en main de façon collective et qu'on les
fasse fonctionner non seulement pour
qu'elle réponde d'abord aux besoins
vitaux un des femmes et des hommes et
pas au caprice de quelques riches mais
aussi pour qu'elle pour qu'elle puisse
pour qu'elle puisse préserver la planète
pour qu'on prenne en considération
effectivement et bien
la limitation de ces ressources
naturelles
[Musique]